welcome to see you playing out see corn
yeah this is a frequent opponent and I
had them recently I don't know what that
was don't we have some Spanish already I
somehow feel like we had this precise
position not entirely sure so again why
would fashioned ruin which keeps scoring
well um it really does III mmmm Jim III
I can take before now normally you
should really take that pawn but he has
night be three okay okay okay there is
some point to that is let's not an f1
yet hmm now that was bad and I should I
should have thought about this for a
little bit longer it takes you for this
night be three now
that's bad yeah I don't like that and I
shouldn't have taken on deform I was
thinking about just taking twice but I
forgot about that night b3 move after
which she conveniently gets the pawn
back so let's do this now I know why it
can probably play before for Bishop
between I'd be three maybe you know
before I have a5 here hmm I wonder yeah
my night probably is not exactly
well-placed 85g 592 a 70 a salmon looks
very ridiculous but maybe c8b six then
ok I want some kind of activity so I'm
going to go away five night on s heaven
looks ridiculous but maybe really be six
can be a good square for that piece t5
looks very very normal no surprising
that's surprising I didn't expect that
move it looks far more active in
comparison ok yes some pressure only
five now maybe that was the the
underlying idea
okay I really have to probably know
something that [ __ ] see one maybe yeah
that's not bad he didn't play that bad
at all interesting so now i mean i can i
can take twice come queen bee 7l it's
not so bad lets do it and i'd be three
years maybe better interesting I don't
think I'm in terrible shape i can always
put the Queen down be 7 p-8 I have so
typical normal removes okay Wow I don't
get it 95
Wow okay so and I takes you five picture
page seven is a little bit much but is
he really see pinning me I don't get it
okay I'm taking that porn show me show
me why thought why that shouldn't work
it's 96 Bishop c6 otero this kind of x
ray pin on the sea fowl I don't I don't
see it at the moment
so what does this now
should be there then move the Queen I
mean if I just go to the six let's say
something bad happening to me I don't
see it better have to speed up probably
had something better I'm not sure you
know what's two pawns up and now after
90 for just one pawn ok let's try to try
to keep it
yes some catching up on the clock that's
good news I'd really like to don't get
get pressure on that night damn what
would have been nice if I get some
pressure there on that night that feels
but ok cannot really move the Queen and
if he moves the night I will probably
just trade that is not bad at all I
wants to go route it to that's a good
idea probably so where do I put it let's
go here no that runs into 95 I was
stupid let's not do that ok maybe I can
trade one rogue at least that took far
too long religion
something like I'm working
Jack okay check their check there and
Queenie one maybe let's try that it's
got Bishop t1 maybe the shop t1 rook a
to maybe now it's not leading to much
and night see to as a threat shouldn't
forget about that move maybe this just
attacking the rock right now my time is
not so great
difficult frame now to not trade ship d7
now i'm not sure what I wanted to cover
five before not sure about it okay is it
taking this that's not good it's kind of
unpleasant covering the same rank and
try to regroup the noid to F form after
which I can and try things at least one
in seconds but fortunately only have in
the symbolic advantage and I think that
happened that really helps me a lot well
our third draw our third round here kind
of offered back and forth yeah of course
I should win this somehow here i'm
basically you have two points up and
later i was one called up for not much
but he was still reasonably active so it
didn't feel like super super easy to
convert maybe before is better yeah that
was all very very decent yeah whoo Kate
Kings Teague's ah he could have taken
already that's a nice tactic Jay and now
this is protected I'm just about just
hold so I hit ok yeah I have this I
really have that porn and
check check and should win somehow it's
not easy in BG 7s bet I am it really is
just as just a pawn now I have good this
one yeah I somehow lost that pawn back
g5 I like to I'd like to fix this on the
light squares but this rookie
five-county placer is annoying I rooks
III was stronger looking at the bishop
yeah that's a lot stronger okay maybe I
was a sort of solid here I cannot lose
anymore really and it's reasonably
simple to to play you know I wonder
about III and of a soul that move I
don't know if my reaction there is great
I don't believe it before in five ya
know t5 looks very normal i was
surprised that he took it here yeah if i
was was amazing i was just thinking it
takes and I thought he is slightly
better like like this here why this a
bit better with the small active pieces
it's not a huge problem also for black
but white is definitely a bit more
active so this looks very very weird now
it was not so bad that it like loses
straight away okay well thanks for
watching